[Risate]
non così tanto
ciao a tutti
nuova challenge trasforma abbiamo qua po
di slime che il live che hanno bisogno
di una giusta tina piccolo cassano sì
perché sono un po vecchi e alcuni sono
induriti ago giochi praticamente noi
chiedemmo la vota in base al numero
pensi topi che dovremmo per stare lo
slime corrispondente e dovranno staccare
di trasformarlo in un live bello fresco
e con bellissimi su di essa che hanno a
disposizione più ma la barca dentifricio
super display p2 it e glitter colorati e
l'opzione e altri coloranti continua li
abbiamo anche altre opzioni nella volta
fate strupri rete minuti sono usa nuovo
poi alla fine del video come sempre
dovrete votare chi ha vinto in base a
quali trasformazioni vi sono piaciute di
più
quindi vi metterò questo da oggi potrete
notare che ha vinto lite tigrotto o
vitale team sera per trasforma gli slide
san luigi la stata bella anche se questo
video realizzati
adesso però fare un secondo figlio di un
come sempre che gesù da titolare nel
video tutto schermo e iniziamo carta poi
miserando andiamo andiamo ad occhi
chiusi quindi chiude gli occhi c'è la
maschera non sono gruppi e quindi il
fido di te io di è bene non mi metta
collocata davanti c'è umberto
scommettono dai ha chiesto numero due
vediamo un pochino devi aggiustare in
questo numero in tv
e allora non puzza era di male questo
slime è duro duro ma si imbarchi le dita
non entro nel duro duro
allora questo va aggiustato tirano fuori
compatto se c'era il play in questo
slancio uno strato quei proprio
sedimentato il claim singoli un pochino
di dentifricio non così tanto
oddio cimino per lo morbido mattino ci
mette la testa dice poi ci mettiamo la
crema ma gli abbiamo fatto il restauro
completo vediamo laviamo i denti primo
tempo sono la piadina si sente già chi è
più morbido vero no
ho paura che questo sia già andato come
si può capitarmi carlo si stanno
sfidando gli mettiamo un po di farina no
ora bisogna però riaggiustarlo meglio
facciamo la focaccia speriamo che questo
non sia troppo lo mettiamo in forno
non sono sicuro che questo penso che già
istituito sia veramente troppo forse lo
abbiamo perso abbiamo mettere più o meno
come più o meno come prima era super
duro adesso un pochino meglio si dà e
darà che sia un po di casino nelle tue
mani noto però dai armati sono
abbastanza pulite dai ha funzionato e
spero da reinventare pensate che voto
date il primo slam trasformato argentato
che vado smonta le stime giorno nel
lazio tornata in azione una ciotola
bellissimo dai sembra un pochino metodo
fai vedere e quasi per dei cake e bravo
bravo bravo
aiutatemi vabbè adesso vediamo
se mi capiterà da gettare speriamo
fossile
[Musica]
e sempre interessante invece di verde ma
appunto non solo apporto per
trasformarlo in molti a più verde si
sono certo gratis convention che lo è
pure che sia un po psicologo vediamo è
leggermente schifoso e verde e più
grossi bilic e questo è stato fatto con
la corda trasparente pensa che carino
[Musica]
un topo oddio palloncino questo è quello
che ho fatto facendo il mobbing balloons
quindi scoppiando i palloncini al buio
se non l'avete visto andate a vederlo
era bellissimo perché i palloncini
luminosi
troppo bello io avevo un sacco di powell
al buio vabbè togliamo questo palloncino
innanzitutto sicuramente andiamo
innanzitutto cambiargli colore e che
colora quindi facciamo e facciamo un
rosa metalli un anno lo vedremo che lo
prenda bene questo colore parolo per
dati ma essendo appiccicosa dovrebbe
prenderlo e bellissimo comune the city
mi piace attenta non sporcarsi le dita
papà vedi chi paga quello che ti
spalmato su le maniche e andare tanto
anita si sporca le dita il verde ma le
catene dimorato annuncino un agglomerato
di colore rosa ma si aspetta non ho
pensato che colore fire rosa con il
verde bisogna sempre pensare queste
combinazioni grigio
ancora guerra gara sta cambiando già
capito allora marina ecco qua in rosa
metto un paio di gocce di rosa così si
colora in diretta siccome chi fretta ma
anche le dita della ditta si coloreranno
con tre mediani portarmi su diaz che
strano detto il colore ma in mezzo si
perde si rifiuta
vediamo le mani voi e resto diventando
la nave salizzato più bello anche le sue
mani vero niente altro potrei non si sa
più cosa raccontiamo
[Musica]
inizialmente più attendibile e profumato
il mio slime trasformato che voto gli
date da una 10 e quindi è diventato rosa
e meno appiccicosa
che bello bravo e fatto molto male va bè
forse non sarà più fortunate con lo
slime è però certo fatevi scappare se vi
piace di più così o se vi piace più come
era prima cioè scusa verde che abbiamo 3
1 6 6 4 per un break in giallo bike
anch'io
[Musica]
che però mi piacerebbe tanto questo però
non lo so forse scelgo abbiamo nemmeno
un set e grigio
vediamo vediamo forse anche questo
lei mi sembra un po duro che booking
castità ormai sono diventato del mago
del pon economia però mostrano come
super crearsi e si è indurito un po il
play in questo sono budino bello budino
zoe che slime bello bo di noto si è un
po l asi quindi il futuro capiscono è
duro qui è un pochino pc così non qui
neanche troppo quindi cosa vuoi per
aggiustarla
la crema forse sono un pò di crea
bastava poco cambiato idea che sia un
paio di eccezioni
crediamo che se c'erano il mio modello
morbidoso lavori batterla chissà che ho
sbagliato in cina dalla porta cava è
sbagliato né un po dure vuoi un po di
andy brita no punti frigio no dopo la
prima esperienza è ma perché mi hai
messo troppo male in tv i cieli
ammorbidisse davvero non lo so mi piace
come crema pochino di schiuma barbona
poka poka basta
hewitt altro può stare attento a non
sporcare tutto il tavolo con un altro
volto sta funzionando secondo voi sono
meno diamo due futuro di prima non
capisco quindi perchè non sono capace a
farli e machista paese questa lato
troppo trasformate completata anno
dobbiamo ancora ammorbidirlo e colorarlo
ma come ben sapete piacenza e bene
infatti magari lo faccio ancora più
verde allora dài diciamo che
innanzitutto è diventato un pochettino
pochettino più elastico che quindi forza
se ci mettiamo un altro pochino di grema
un po sparsa quella somma regista
facendo sempre la forma della focaccia
si vede che te la vuoi mangiare allora
mettiamo un pochettino dichiarava
quell'altro
a parte vediamo che cosa uscirà fuori ma
facciamo un po lo slime no ma per fare
infiltrare meglio la guerra è che la
cremo così adesso però morbidity per non
sentirmi introdotte ma adesso stiamo
contrastando il pane allora salsicciotto
di slime quindi è finito questo drive
allora lo dichiari morto pur sempre
anche questo qui purtroppo un'isola che
si è ammorbidito ma io te l'ho detto
dopo che dopo l'esperienza passata con
te però non male pochino più allungabile
lo è davvero a quello footing
che bello adesso tutta uniforme
wow che che slide fantastico ok prossimo
[Musica]
dell streak questo deforme e toccamenti
ingrosso vediamo quale mi capita
[Musica]
numero due
no è cambiato numero tre amiche due non
c'era
leimer rosa con pallini
ora mettiamo un po a un capello è
durissimo papa sì però bellissimo questa
superficie puri buono solo qua allora è
più morbido suoni sentite
[Musica]
però fa sotto e appiccicoso sopra e duro
quindi innanzitutto lo mischia un po le
besco ritirarsi o altro dei suoi
bellissimi allora vedi altro stato tra
l'altro la settimana in la consistenza è
abbastanza buona davis bucari aggiungo
un pochino di schiuma da barba così lo
rende un pochino più la foto vediamo un
po come diventa la vera ma c'è l'uomo
discuterà un po all'inizio ma è normale
quando non mischiate che si sta
ammorbidendo
e ora profumata anche schiuma da barba
sta diventando molto più allungabile
quindi sta funzionando bene e anche
molti che i suoni poi voglia me
chiuderei ravvivato anche un po il
colore sì credo di sì voglio mettere un
po di viola con i glitter e giusto per
rendere il colore un po più particolare
vediamo un po come diventa buona idea se
ci incollato qua eccola la schiuma da
barba la appunto reso un po più tortuoso
e creati su polle così fa con i pranzi
che direi che mi fermo qui mi piace
molto
facilissimo nick anzi il colore mi piace
e se ammorbidito
cosa ne pensate di questa mini
trasformazione ed è stato graziato però
altri più folle ok quindi per te la mia
seconda trasformazione e non so quale
scegliere adesso d'andrè vicende da
allora 16 ci salviamo
[Musica]
questo sistema di mondovì che ammette
come stai girando non era un bambino o
marino tutto perdendo i pezzi fatto
proprio allora è molto bello il colore
di questo slime perché a tantissimi
glitter però è molto duro il parrocco
prova a tirarla attirarlo sarda tutti
gli amanti ni mh test proprio vecchio
alla sapore come butta
allora io poi aggiungere un po di
dentifricio ancora studente di prigione
per ammorbidirlo bene si vediamo io
tutti questi di umberto è un'impresa
impossibile difficili da recuperare però
da te la puoi fare
rimuoviamo prima tutti via mazzini
proprio come sono un restauratore disney
non professionista minatore è stato
bravo e ho preso solo una puntina di
dentinale spalmiamo fortino toccarla
stiletti prima che sia già con zanetti
bottone questo sicuramente è stato fatto
ma sale lo stesso e questo lo trovo lì
fuori e allora si fa un bel con dove
bisogna togliere le colazioni quella che
cadono e ammorbidirlo perbene ma
funziona dove ha detto che funziona
addio la maglietta dai siamo a buon
punto mi sembra che si sia ammorbidito
un bel po adesso di frizzo ha migliorato
molto adesso mettiamo anche un poco poco
di schiuma da barba
per farlo più famoso i cupi le cose
significa che vediamo vediamo vediamo
che cos'è share voli in più hai tolto la
maggior parte delle decorati e le ho
dovute togliere perché cane ma tu stai
ci siamo quasi adesso facciamo
incorporare tutta la scuola materna
questo era difficile da fare è infatti
molto meglio adesso giacché un bel po
allungabile ci ricordate i glitter come
si vedono bene iscritte un po così con
la schiuma da barba perso un po di
colore no bene ora belli e più morbidi
formativi da questa è quella che è
uscita la migliore che mi uccido delle
tre miss l'anno prima questa è la prima
di un sito molto clienti voi cosa ne
pensate sistemi che scrivete nei
commenti
ma questo era molto difficile quindi
secondo me questo è uscita la mente ora
un po di glitter fa sul tavolo però
voler poi morisco lo steri spalmando
dovesse avere denti turismo così con
situazioni dialisi ottima perché dai
male ma la trasformate completa società
è molto più bello adesso ho recuperato
lo chiama buttata nel qualche bellino
come nuovo
devo dire che è meglio anche di sony
paul king molto più morbido e senza
decorazioni che si riesce a giocare
meglio allora è rimasto solo un lime e
quindi toccherà per un desk ora il
numero uno che è già bello che è
fortissimo innovare perché siamo mai
super sciolto quindi ora andiamo a
trasformarlo da giusto mi sembra
bellissimo grossi però purtroppo è super
folk una possibile questo con il caldo
perché queste proprio vecchio peggio
allora prima di tirarlo fuori dalla
ciotola aggiungo un po disposizione per
niente altrimenti si attesterà tutto al
tavolo giungo pochissimo bicarbonato di
sodio mi raccomando poco poco se non
rischia di indurirsi essendo vecchio
piano piano sta solidificando gigi
buffon che sono troppo troppo liquidi
bisogna aggiungere un po di colla
però questo non mi sembra il caso perché
ci vuole solo un po di pazienza
la telefono del tutto vorrei aggiungere
qualcosa perché è troppo semplice questo
slime vorrei farlo un po diversi studi
sr non sono granché quindi è poco da
aggiungere ti dico sì diciamo
trasformarlo in un bel giappone come nel
frattempo sta diventando sempre meno
pescoso ok ora decisamente non è più
appiccicoso però non è ancora bello
fluff foto azione per renderlo più
elastico kiuva mezzo secolo infatti ora
farò un casino però poi ne varrà la pena
a casa a napoli dott
il timore ad un mescolato per un sacco
di tempo
siccome si è schiarito un sacco con la
schiuma da barba e la nozione commesso
un po di tintarella metallizzata vediamo
che si amalgami veneto 20
anche questa sembra una big babol
gigante si sono sopra l'astico è
diventato molto più elastico la
consistenza è sempre un po cicli però
perché ovviamente inizialmente raggi
glik quindi successo la tinta io spero
che non macchina permanentemente il
tavolo che le tue mani sotto allora
eccolo qua mi sembrava il più semplice
da fare invece stato di più complicato
stavano complicatissimo non mi chiedo
per un sacco di tempo ma per fortuna ed
in entrato più soffice purtroppo non è
più appiccicoso chiama così il più bello
il colorate va bene ha distrutto le mani
a quello proust live trasformato quindi
cosa ne pensate di queste trasformazioni
per la trasformazione di eps tappe di
tutti mi lascio quali soldato in cui
potete votare sia mentalità io vostra
mente un'italia che vi lasciamo le
quattro piazze lines criticare
prevederebbe inoltre altre challenge
ufficiale scola ruota eseguite
divertenti slime facebook a quella che
preferite emulazione ciao